يعني نحن على ثلاثين كيلو
اصعب على روسيا اوكرانيا هنا من المكان
الذي يقف به كنا نرى بالامس ليلا عندما
ساد الظلام في المدينه ونسمع صوت المدافع
ونرى من هنا اضواء تاتي من الجهه الجنوب
شرقيه
عند الوصول الى المدينه هناك اكثر من مشهد
يمكن وصفه الاول يغيب وجود المدنيين هنا
وخصوصا بعد الظهر لا يخرج المدنيون بعد
الظهر الى الشارع وكان هناك خوف
برغم من ان الجو
يخرجون الى الشارع المشهد الثاني هو وجود
مكثف
للعسكريين لسيارات العسكريه للسيارات
العسكريه سواء كانت اليات صغيره او كبيره
لجنود تحدثت الى الى مدنيين هذا الصباح
قالت لي فتاه اسمها ارينا تبلغ من العمر
25 عاما قالت لي في البدايه كنا خائفين
هنا عشنا صعبه جدا ولكن عندما استعاد
الجيش الاوكراني مدينه خيسن ومناطق في كيف
اصبح لنا ثقه اكبر فانا لا افكر حتى الوضع
اترك مدينه مدينه اكرام اثق
ث للجنود هنا تحدثت الجنود
في
رائد ابو زيده موفدنا الى كراماتورسك
سنضطر الى ان نتوقف عند هذا الحد من
المعلومات بسبب رداءه الصوت نعتذر مش